now more than ever we need to keep
ourselves healthy and strong but local
doctors are getting concerned that many
southern nevadans are putting off
routine health care this year
denise valdez tells us one clinic group
has seen a dramatic drop
in immunizations and vaccines in today's
health clinic hi denise
hi there brian so i spoke with a family
practitioner from southwest medical this
afternoon
who has seen a 43 decline in
immunizations for children's and adults
now she realizes that during the
shutdown a lot of families just didn't
even want to leave the house but
safety protocols at medical facilities
now are really just standard
operating procedure it's very safe so as
we head
deep now into flu season patients should
feel confident
coming in for exams and annual shots and
kids too
so i definitely still strongly encourage
patients to receive their flu shot
i would remind them that it does offer a
lot of great protection
and immunity even though it's not
against coping specifically
that can really protect their
respiratory health
and hopefully that would convince them
to be compliant in receiving it this
year even if they haven't in the past
now schroeder worries that a lot of
families are just falling through the
cracks by putting their health on the
back burner
remember most doctors practice great
safety measures inside their offices
plus there's also telemedicine or face
time if you want to get in touch with
your doctor
and by the way southwest medical also
has a mobile clinic
and it does offer dispatch services
where people can come right to your home
good stuff to not put off your health
care